>> THIS IS A JOB THAT REQUIRES
HONESTY.
YOU CAN CALL ME OLD-FASHIONED.
BUT I STILL THINK CHARACTER
MATTERS.
INTEGRITY MATTERS.
TELLING THE TRUTH MATTERS.
COMPETENCE MATTERS.
BRIAN: WOW, IT'S GETTING
PERSONAL.
GEORGIA SENATOR RAFAEL WARNOCK
TAKES A SHOT AT HERSCHEL WALKER.
WALKER HAULED IN $3.3 MILLION
FROM FRIDAY.
THE DEMOCRATS DUMPED $7 MILLION
INTO WARNOCK'S RACE.
THEY SPENT ANOTHER $7 MILLION
DURING THE INITIAL MATCHUP
BETWEEN THESE TWO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU HERSCHEL, I KNOW
YOU ARE BACK IN YOUR HOUSE,
READY TO GO.
WHEN YOU FIRST FOUND OUT NOBODY
WAS GOING TO GET TO 50%, WHAT
WAS YOUR REACTION?
>> I AM BUILT FOR THIS.
I'M READY TO GO IN A RUNOFF
BECAUSE THIS MEANS MORE THAN YOU
JUST HERSCHEL WALKER AND
ANYTHING I HAVE BEEN DOING.
THIS IS ABOUT THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE.
IT SEEMS SENATOR WARNOCK HAS
LOST.
MY INTEGRITY AND HONESTY IS
BETTER THAN HE IS.
HE HAS HIDDEN EVERYTHING HE HAS
EVER DONE IN HIS LIFE.
HE HAS LIVED ON THE TAXPAYER
DOLLAR AND HIS PARISHIONER'S
DOLLARS.
AND I HAVE BUILT COMPANIES.
I WAS THE ADULT IN THE ROOM IN
THE DEBATES.
ONCE HE GOT CALLED ON THE
APARTMENT HE TOTALLY WENT BLANK
AND HE WAS EXPOSED.
BUT LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT WHAT HE
HAS COMMON HIS PERSONAL LIFE.
BUT WHAT HE HAS DONE AS A
SENATOR.
BRIAN: HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
YOUR PERSONAL LIFE, HE WASN'T
DOING THAT AT FIRST.
IS IT TIME TO LOOK INTO HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH REVEREND
WRIGHT AND LEWIS FARRAKHAN?
IF HE GOES THERE, ARE YOU GOING
TO GO TO THIS PERSONAL LIFE?
>> I TOLD MY CAMPAIGN, THAT'S
FOR OUTSIDE GROUPS TO DO.
I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW WHAT I'M
GOING TO DO FOR THEM AS A SNROR.
AND HE FAILED THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE.
WHAT I'M GOING TO DO AS A
SENATOR IS BE SENATORIAL.
HE'S NOT.
HE'S BROKEN ALMOST EVERY
COMMANDMENT HE CAN BREAK.
IF HE CAN'T KEEP THE OATH TO
ALMIGHTY GOD, DO YOU THINK HE'S
GOING TO KEEP IT FOR YOU?
HE'S OFF THE HINGES RIGHT NOW.
HE NEVER THOUGHT HE WOULD BE IN
A RUNOFF.
I WANTED TO WIN IT OUTRIGHT.
I AM BUILT FOR HIS.
HE FEELS HE CAN BUY HIS SEAT.
GEORGIA IS NOT FOR SALE.
HE NEEDS TO KNOW THAT GEORGIA IS
NOT FOR SALE.
I'M HERE TO WIN THIS FOR THE
GEORGIA PEOPLE.
THEY HAVELESS MONEY IN THEIR --
THEY HAVE LESS MONEY IN THEIR
POCKETS.
TWO YEARS AGO THEY HAD MORE.
THE BORDER WAS SECURED.
TWO YEARS AGO IT WAS SECURED.
NOW IT'S NOT.
IT'S ONLY BECAUSE OF HIM.
BRIAN: IN OVERTIME YOU WILL NEED
A DIFFERENT STRATEGY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
ONE THING IS CLEAR.
MITCH McCONNELL IS TAPPING
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP TO LOAN YOU
THE GET-OUT-THE-VOTE MACHINE
THAT WORKED FOR HIM INCLUDING
HIS ANALYTICS AND DOOR KNOCKING
CAMPAIGN AND THE SUPER PAC TO
LOAN YOU MONEY TO HELP YOU OUT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I FEEL GREAT ABOUT GOVERNOR
KEMP AND HIS ADVISORS.
WHEN I GET TO THE SENATE I WILL
WORK WITH HIM ON A FEDERAL LEVEL
AND HE WILL WORK ON A STATE
LEVEL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE GOT TO
HAVE.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A PERSON IN
WASHINGTON WORKING AGAINST THE
GOVERNOR.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAD IN WASHINGTON
WITH SENATOR WARNOCK.
RIGHT NOW HE CAN HAVE SOMEONE IN
WASHINGTON THAT WILL WORK ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND WORK WITH HIM.
ANY HELP I CAN GET FROM GOVERNOR
KEMP, I'M SAYING PLEASE HELP ME.
ANYONE IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA I
WANT TO HELP ME WIN THIS RACE.
THIS RACE IS ABOUT THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE.
BRIAN: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
RUNDOWN AND SAW WHO DIDN'T VOTE
FOR YOU, HOW DOES THAT FIGURE
INTO YOUR STRATEGY LEADING UP TO
DECEMBER 6.
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY THEY
DIDN'T VOTE FOR YOU IN GREAT
NUMBERS.
IS THAT A PLACE YOU WANT TO
REVISIT AND FINDS OUT THE
MESSAGE THEY WANT TO HEAR?
>> I DO WANT TO VISIT THAT AREA.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
GOT TO QUIT DOING, SEPARATING
THE BLACK AND HISPANIC VOTES.
SEPARATING THE PEOPLE VOTE.
I AM GOING TO WORK FOR
EVERYBODY.
I WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE A
QUALITY EDUCATION AND THE
AMERICAN DREAM I HAVE.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN GET THAT IS
TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AND
HAVE A SENATOR IN WASHINGTON
THAT WILL FIGHT FOR EVERYONE WHO
HAS THE QUALITY YOU DESERVE TO
HAVE.
BRIAN: WHAT ABOUT HIS VOTE THAT
MIGHT APPEAL TO MAKE THEM YOUR
VOTERS?
>> THE WAY YOU GET TO THAT VOTE,
YOU HAVE GOT TO TALK TO THOSE
PEOPLE AND LET THEM KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ELECTION IS.
LET THEM KNOW WHO THEY ARE
FIGHTING FOR.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR POCKETBOOK AND RETIREMENT.
RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW INTO YOUR
RETIREMENT TO LIVE.
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE TOTALLY
DESTROYING YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
AND DESTROYING EVERYTHING ABOUT
WHAT AMERICA WAS GREAT ABOUT.
THIS IS HAPPENING IN LESS THAN
TWO SHORT YEARS.
CAN WE GIVE THEM SIX MORE YEARS?
BRIAN: YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
EVERYBODY JOINING ON THE STUMP.
WE'LL BE TRACKING YOU EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THANKS SO MUCH, BEST OF LUCK.
>> GO TO teamHerschel.com.
THEY HAVE